Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. What if it was a mistake from the start? The Declaration of Independence, the American Revolution, the creation of the United States of America. What if all this was a terrible idea? And what if the injustices and madness of American life since then have occurred not in spite of the virtues of the
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如果这一切从一开始就是个错误呢？《独立宣言》、美国独立战争、美利坚合众国的建立。如果这一切都是个糟糕的主意呢？如果自那以后美国生活中发生的不公正与疯狂，其根源并非不顾国父们的
founding fathers, but because of them. The revolution, this argument might run, was a needless and brutal bit of slaveholders' panic mixed with Enlightenment argle-bargle, producing a country that was always marked for violence and disruption and demagogy. Look north to Canada, or south south to Australia and you will see different possibilities of peaceful evolution away from Britain towards sane and whole, more equitable and less sanguinary countries. No revolution and slavery might have ended, as it did elsewhere in the British Empire, more peacefully and sooner. We could have ended with a social democratic commonwealth that stretched from north to south, a near continent-wide Canada.
美德，恰恰相反，正是由于这些美德。这种观点可能会认为，这场革命不过是一场毫无必要且残忍的奴隶主恐慌，混杂着启蒙运动的空洞言辞，催生了一个自诞生起就打上暴力、动乱和煽动烙印的国家。看看北边的加拿大，或者南边的澳大利亚，你会看到摆脱英国、走向理智完整、更加公平且不那么嗜血的国家这一和平演变的另一种可能。如果没有这场革命，奴隶制可能早就和英帝国其他地方一样，更和平、更迅速地终结了。我们最终可能会迎来一个从北延伸到南的社会民主联邦，一个几乎覆盖整个大陆的加拿大。
Wow. So that, Tom, was Adam Gopnik, a very great essayist, in The New Yorker in May 2017, asking if the American Revolution was a mistake from the start. And of course, you and I will have our own opinions about why or not it was a mistake. But the fact is that as we reach episode four of this mighty epic, we are in, what, 1778. The French and soon the Spanish have piled in, or in Spanish case, will pile in.
哇。汤姆，刚才那是亚当·戈普尼克（Adam Gopnik），《纽约客》的一位伟大散文家，他在2017年5月发表的文章中，探讨了美国独立战争是否从一开始就是一个错误。当然，你我都对它究竟是不是一个错误有着自己的看法。但事实是，当我们进入这部宏大史诗的第四集时，时间已经来到了1778年。法国人，以及不久后的西班牙人也介入了，或者按西班牙的情况来说，即将介入。
And they will be followed by other countries who form a league of armed neutrality, the Russians, the Danes, the Prussians, the Austrians, the Portuguese, basically making it very difficult for the British. And from this point, don't you think, Tom, the game is kind of up for Britain? I think the game has been up right from the start. I don't think there was any prospect of the British ever. You think it was unwinnable from the beginning? Yeah, I do.
紧随其后的是其他国家，它们组成了武装中立同盟，包括俄国人、丹麦人、普鲁士人、奥地利人、葡萄牙人，这基本上让英国人举步维艰。汤姆，从这个角度来看，你不觉得英国人已经彻底没戏了吗？我认为英国人从一开始就没戏了。我不认为英国人曾有过任何……你觉得从一开始这就是一场不可能取胜的战争吗？是的，我确实这么认为。
So Adam Smith, Professor Adam Smith, who is the Edward Osborne Professor of American History at the University of Oxford, who has been performing manfully in these four episodes. Adam, do you think the game was up from the very beginning? I think the game was up if the goal was a restoration of the status quo as it had been before 1775 i think other alternatives might have been possible i think if you know if we talked about in the previous episode if washington's army had been captured if saratoga hadn't fallen i mean there are other options yeah but the possibility is narrow and narrow and narrow and definitely by the time you get to the french intervention which is where we ended the last episode it's very very, very difficult to see how the British get out of this. And yet the funny thing is you mentioned Washington.
那么亚当·史密斯教授，他是牛津大学的爱德华·奥斯本美国历史讲座教授，在这四集节目中表现得非常出色。亚当，你觉得从一开始英国就输定了吗？我认为，如果目标是恢复1775年之前那样的现状，那英国确实是从一开始就输定了。我认为其他可能性或许存在，比如我们在上一集讨论过的，如果华盛顿的军队被俘虏了，如果萨拉托加没有失守——我是说，确实还有其他选项。是的，但这种可能性越来越窄、越来越窄，到了法国干预的时候——也就是我们上一集结束的地方——要看出英国人如何脱身，已经变得非常、非常、非常困难了。然而有趣的是，你提到了华盛顿。
So Washington at this point, I mean, he's the great hero for the Americans, obviously, commander of the Continental Army. At the point that the French get involved, he is really in the depths of despondency, isn't he? Because Philadelphia had been taken by the British and he has led his army into winter quarters, a place called Valley Forge, which is about just under 20 miles Northwest of Philadelphia. And he's there for six months and they've got nothing to eat. It's freezing cold. They're
所以在此时此刻，华盛顿对美国人来说无疑是个伟大的英雄，他是大陆军总司令。在法国人介入的时候，他其实正处于极度沮丧的低谷，对吧？因为费城被英国人攻陷了，他率领军队进入了冬营，一个叫做福吉谷（Valley Forge）的地方，大约在费城西北不到20英里处。他在那里呆了六个月，一无所有，冻得要命。他们
really miserable. And Valley Forge is this sort of, so Ronald Reagan, big favorite of yours, Tom, of course, Ronald Reagan used to tell this story about Washington kneeling in prayer at Valley Forge and asking God for help. And Valley Forge is a really important part of the American mythology of the revolution and the war, isn't it? Because it's sort of, again, it's the underdog spirit. The odds are against us. And, you know, God was with us.
真的非常悲惨。福吉谷就是这样一个地方——罗纳德·里根，你的最爱，汤姆，罗纳德·里根过去常常讲这样一个故事：华盛顿在福吉谷跪地祈祷，向上帝寻求帮助。福吉谷是美国关于革命和战争的神话中非常重要的一部分，对吧？因为它再次体现了劣势者的精神。胜算对我们不利，而且，你知道，上帝与我们同在。
Providence was with us. Do you think it really deserves that reputation, Adam? Well, it was another moment when it's easy to imagine how the Continental Army could have completely dispersed. And if that had happened, the calculations would have shifted. It's not to say that there wouldn't have been some other kind of military force that would have been put together, perhaps under Washington, perhaps under somebody else. But it was certainly a desperate moment.
天意与我们同在。亚当，你觉得它真的配得上这样的名声吗？嗯，那也是一个很容易让人想象大陆军彻底溃散的时刻。如果那种情况真的发生了，局势的计算就会发生变化。这并不是说不会有其他某种军事力量被组建起来，也许在华盛顿的领导下，也许在其他人的领导下。但那绝对是一个绝望的时刻。
And the reason, as you say, Dominic, I mean, the reason why it's become so much part of the myth of the American Revolution in the United States is because it reinforces this underdog narrative and in that Reaganite way, because it implies at least that it's only because of God's providence that it was possible in the end for the Americans to triumph. God and women. Am I right? Martha Washington is there too. I don't know anything about Martha Washington, but she's followed George and she's there sort of bandaging people and, I don't know, making soup or something that sounds like i'm being flippant about but obviously women play a huge part in the american revolution from the beginning yeah not least in following their husbands or their boyfriends with the army and they do all the important stuff behind the lines like yeah washing their clothes bandaging their
正如你所说，多米尼克，它之所以如此深入美国独立战争的神话，是因为它强化了这种弱者逆袭的叙事，并带有一种里根式的色彩——因为它至少暗示了，正是因为上帝的天意，美国人才最终得以取得胜利。上帝和女性。我说的对吗？玛莎·华盛顿也在那里。我对玛莎·华盛顿一无所知，但她跟随乔治来到了那里，在那里给伤员包扎伤口，我不知道，煮汤什么的——听起来我好像在开玩笑，但显然女性从一开始就在美国独立革命中发挥了巨大的作用。是的，不仅在于她们跟随丈夫或男友加入军队，还在于她们在后方做了所有重要的事情，比如洗衣服、包扎伤
wounds providing them with food all those things which an army absolutely depends on well thomas paine has a brilliant description of the whole setup with all the men who were busy building up the fortifications and the women laboring. And he says that it was like a family of beavers. That's nice. You like a beaver, Tom. I love a beaver, yes. But Adam, so women in the American Revolution, we haven't talked about women much, but they are, I mean, historiography now really plays up the part that women played in a way that wouldn't have been the case 100 years ago.
口、提供食物，所有军队绝对依赖的事情。托马斯·杰斐逊——哦不，托马斯·潘恩对整个阵地有一个精彩的描述，所有的男人们都在忙着修建防御工事，女人们则在一旁辛勤劳作。他说这就像一个海狸家族。真不错。你喜欢海狸，汤姆。我当然喜欢海狸，是的。不过亚当，女性在美国独立革命中的作用，我们之前没有怎么谈过，但现在史学界确实高度评价了女性所扮演的角色，这在100年前是不可想象的。
And critically so, because this was a war which, as we've in effect been emphasising, was won or lost by the American white colonial public and their commitment to this cause. And so it was in American households that sacrifices were made, that commitments were made to try to wait out this through this time of trial. The presence of the Redcoats, the presence of the army in itself intensified American commitment to try to, that the only possible outcome with any honour was complete victory, complete independence, removing British troops forever from American soil. King George had already been taken down. None of that is explicable if the only focus is on the men in the armies and the generals making the decisions on the American side and the founding fathers who are all of course men but of course there's a there's isn't a famous exchange
而且这至关重要，正如我们一直在强调的那样，这场战争的胜负是由美国白人殖民地公众及其对这一事业的承诺所决定或失去的。正因如此，牺牲是在美国家庭中做出的，坚守这段艰难时期、度过难关的承诺也是在美国家庭中做出的。红衫军的存在、军队本身的出现，加剧了美国人的决心，使他们坚信唯一体面的结果就是彻底的胜利、彻底的独立，将英国军队永远清除出美洲大陆。乔治国王已经被推翻了。所有这一切，如果把焦点仅仅放在军队中的士兵、美方做出决定的将军们，以及国父们身上——当然他们全都是男性——是根本无法解释的。不过，难道没有一封著名的
of letters abigail adams is abigail adams yes john adams wife yeah where she writes to him when they're passing the declaration of independence and says you know while you're remaking the world think about women as well forget the ladies to get the ladies and he sort of writes back in this incredibly condescending way and says yeah right you know like we're gonna do that like we're gonna give you a second's thought or something so was there ever he does he does although in fairness i mean that's actually a magnificent exchange of letters i mean john and abigail adams write to each other they're apart most of the time throughout this whole revolutionary crisis. And he clearly takes her incredibly seriously as a kind of counsellor and source of advice. And he tests out ideas with her and he wants to know what she thinks and what people around her back in Boston are thinking. So it's actually quite a really impressive and interesting close political relationship,
书信交流吗？阿比盖尔·亚当斯——是阿比盖尔·亚当斯，对吧，约翰·亚当斯的妻子？她在他通过《独立宣言》时写信给他，说：“你知道，当你在重塑世界时，也请考虑一下女性。”别忘了女士们。忘了女士们。而他以一种极其居高临下的态度回信说：“好吧，行吧，你知道的，就好像我们会那样做，就好像我们会花一秒钟去考虑你们一样。”所以，曾经有过……他确实这么回了——尽管平心而论，这实际上是一组非常了不起的信件。我是说，约翰和阿比盖尔·亚当斯在整个革命危机的大部分时间里都分隔两地，但他们一直保持着书信往来。他显然非常重视她，把她当作一种顾问和建议的来源。他会跟她探讨各种想法，想知道她的看法以及波士顿老家周围的人都在想什么。所以，这实际上是一种非常令人印象深刻、有趣且紧密的政治关系，
as well as emotional one between John and Abigail. So could there have been a more, as it were, a more progressive outcome for women, for the poor, for slaves, for people who are pushed to the margins of kind of American political life? Or was it always going to play out as it did? But doesn't, I mean, doesn't the war is kind of bad for slaves because they are seen as having sided with the British. So in a way, the kind of bad for slaves because they are seen as having sided with the British. So in a way, the structures of oppression become a titan as a result of the Revolutionary War. Yeah, well, I think gender and class work out in different ways from
当然也是约翰和阿比盖尔之间一种充满情感的关系。那么，对于女性、对于穷人、对于奴隶，对于那些被推到美国政治生活边缘的人来说，有没有可能出现一个更具进步意义的结果呢？还是说这一切注定只能按实际发生的那样展开？不过，难道这场战争对奴隶来说不是挺糟糕的吗，因为他们被视为站在了英国人一边？从某种意义上说，压迫结构因为独立战争而变得更加坚不可摧了。是的，我认为性别和阶级在美国革命中与
race in the American Revolution. And there is a moment in the 1790s when women are enfranchised. In New Jersey, famously, they're kind of almost accidentally enfranchised if they're property owners, some women, a tiny number of women. In terms of poor white men, the American Revolution was almost everywhere a great boon, and some of the new state constitutions that are being written around about this time, Pennsylvania being the best example, are incredibly radical constitutions that give huge amounts of power
种族的作用方式有所不同。在1790年代的某个时刻，女性获得了选举权。在纽泽西州，著名的是，如果她们拥有财产，她们几乎是“意外地”获得了选举权——虽然只是一小部分女性。对于贫穷的白人男性来说，美国革命几乎在所有地方都是一件大好事，当时正在编写的一些新州宪法（宾夕法尼亚州是最好的例子）极其激进，它们将巨量的权力赋予了
to ordinary white property-less men relative to anywhere else in the world or that really has ever been properly dreamed of anywhere in the world other than, you know, at the most radical extreme moments of the English Revolution of the 1640s. What about, let's say, Indians, so Native Americans? So the British are trying to enlist Native Americans as allies. And in fact, throughout all this period, there's very bloody fighting in the Western borderlands, the kind of frontier zone. Does the American Revolution work out well or badly?
普通的、没有财产的白人男性，其程度超越了世界上任何其他地方，或者说超越了以往任何地方真正敢于梦想的程度（除了1640年代英国革命最激进的极端时刻外）。那么，比方说印第安人，也就是美洲原住民呢？英国人一直在争取美洲原住民作为盟友。事实上，在整个这段时期，西部边境地区——也就是前线地带——发生了非常血腥的战斗。美国独立革命对他们来说是好是坏？
Well, I mean, I'm guessing what your answer is going to be. The answer is not well for Native Americans. And is that because previously they had just been seen as King George's subjects like any others, but now they are seen as enemies? Yeah, I guess for the reasons we were talking about in the first episode, it was in the interest of policymakers in London to try to balance
嗯，我想我能猜到你的答案是什么。答案是对美洲原住民来说并不好。这是因为以前他们只是被当作和其他人一样的乔治国王的臣民，但现在他们被视为敌人了吗？是的，我想正如我们在第一集里讨论过的那样，伦敦的决策者们有动机去试图在北美强大的土著民族与白人定居者之间维持平衡。
the powerful indigenous nations in North America against white settlers. And the French did the same. The French were making alliances with Native Americans. The practical effects of American independence was that Native American peoples were then regarded as being essentially fair game within the boundaries of the newly established United States.
法国人也这么做过。法国人曾与美洲原住民结盟。而美国独立的实际影响是，美洲原住民随后被视为新建立的美利坚合众国国境内的“合法猎物”。
And no, the American Revolution was clearly a bad thing from the point of view of indigenous people. And Adam, just to follow up on that, that the Native Americans are seen as having allied themselves with the British, and presumably even more so that's the case with slaves in the South who have not only escaped their owners, but in certain cases have actually joined the British army. So there's a famous Ethiopian regiment, it's called. And then there's a squad of black dragoons who are enrolled in the British army. Black loyalists play an important role and not a role that's dwelt in traditionally in American historiography until the last couple of decades.
不，从土著人民的角度来看，美国革命显然是一件坏事。亚当，接着刚才的话题，美洲原住民被视为与英国人结盟，而南方的奴隶情况显然更是如此——他们不仅逃离了主人，在某些情况下甚至真正加入了英军。有一个著名的“埃塞俄比亚团”。然后还有编入英军的黑人龙骑兵小队。黑人效忠派扮演了重要角色，尽管在过去的几十年里，这一角色在传统美国史学中并没有得到充分的阐述。
And the Ethiopian regiment, I think, was originally raised by Lord Dunmore and was a direct consequence of the proclamation that we talked about in a previous episode. One of the soldiers in the Ethiopian regiment, Harry Washington, was owned by George Washington, been born in the Gambia, purchased by Washington some 10 or 15 years before the war, ran away when he heard of Dunmore's proclamation and fought for the king throughout the Revolutionary War, was eventually, I think, among those black loyalists who were evacuated by the British and settled in Nova Scotia. So what was it, the phrase, sometimes liberty wears a red coat or something? Just throwing that out for our American listeners. Yeah, there are surely no American listeners left.
埃塞俄比亚团最初是由邓莫尔勋爵（Lord Dunmore）组建的，这是我们在前一集讨论过的那个公告的直接后果。埃塞俄比亚团中的一名士兵哈里·华盛顿（Harry Washington）曾是乔治·华盛顿的奴隶，出生于冈比亚，在战争爆发前大约10到15年被华盛顿买下。当他听说邓莫尔的公告后便逃跑了，并在整个独立战争期间为国王效力。最终，我想他成了被英国人撤离并安置在新斯科舍省的那些黑人效忠派之一。那个短语是怎么说的来着？有时候自由穿着一件红军服什么的？我把这个抛给我们的美国听众。是的，现在肯定没有美国听众留下了。
So let's get back to something that will be cheerier for American listeners, namely the gradual implosion of the British war effort. So we ended the last episode, February 1778, the French piling in. The Spanish have joined a year later. And that obviously, as we were saying before, completely changes the dynamic.
那么让我们回到一个对美国听众来说会更轻松的话题，即英国战争努力的逐渐崩溃。我们在上一集结束时讲到，1778年2月，法国人介入了。西班牙人在一年后加入了。正如我们之前所说，这显然彻底改变了局势。
Because they wanted to brought it back. I mean, that's basically what they want. The Spanish do indeed. But of course, for the British, it's not just defending the Caribbean. They also know how to defend Britain. I mean, so Adam, the chances of a French invasion, I suppose they're not enormous, but they're not negligible either. I mean, the British are always worried of a French invasion, I suppose they're not enormous, but they're not negligible either.
因为他们想要夺回失地。我的意思是，这基本上就是他们想要的。西班牙人确实如此。但当然，对英国人来说，这不仅仅是保卫加勒比海的问题。他们还得知道如何保卫英国本土。亚当，法国入侵的可能性——我想虽然算不上巨大，但也绝对不容忽视吧？我的意思是，在这个时期，英国人总是担心法国人会入侵本土，对吧？
I mean, the British are always worried about a French invasion in this period, aren't they? Yeah, I mean, this isn't just theoretical. There was an armada, the Armada of 1779, Dominic. and Spanish Navy attempted at the very least to kind of divert Britain from the war in the Americas and in the Caribbean and all these other places Britain was trying to defend. But, you know, with a genuine prospect of landing in Great Britain. And the most famous kind of naval innovation in this is that the French government commissions an American called John Paul Jones, who's a kind of former slave ship captain, to actually go and raid the British coast, which he does with some success.
是的，我的意思是这不仅仅是理论上的。多米尼克，1779年确实有一支无敌舰队——1779年的无敌舰队。法国和西班牙海军至少曾试图以此分散英国在美洲、加勒比海以及英国试图保卫的其他所有地方的兵力。但这确实带有在英国本土登陆的真实可能性。海军在这方面最著名的创新之一是，法国政府委任了一个名叫约翰·保罗·琼斯（John Paul Jones）的美国人——他曾是一名奴隶船船长——去突袭英国海岸，而他确实取得了一些成功。
Whitehaven. Yeah, he shells Whitehaven and Cumberland. He's still quite remembered there. If you go to Whitehaven, where there is, by the way, an excellent secondhand bookshop, John Paul Jones is still remembered in might even rightly say and he he ends up taking shelter in the netherlands which i think reflects very poorly on the dutch that they allowed him in so his life then takes a series of very bizarre twists tom he um he ends up in russia after that he's accused of raping a 10 year old girl and um he goes to poland and then he goes back to Paris and he ends up being made US consul in Algiers. Of course. Yes, of course he does.
怀特黑文。是的，他炮轰了怀特黑文和坎布里亚。那里的人们至今仍对他记忆犹新。如果你去怀特黑文——顺便说一句，那里有一家极棒的二手书店——约翰·保罗·琼斯仍然被人们铭记，人们甚至可以说他……最后他在荷兰寻求庇护，这我认为对荷兰人来说很不光彩，因为他们居然允许他入境。他的人生随后经历了一系列极其离奇的转折，汤姆。他后来去了俄国，在那里被指控强奸了一名10岁的小女孩，然后他去了波兰，接着又回到了巴黎，最后竟然成了美国驻阿尔及利亚的领事。当然。是的，他当然会这样。
Yes. Against the slavers. But then dies before he can take up his, he's found dead in his Paris apartment. Isn't that a strange life? There's the plot of a thriller. Yes. Anyway, that's all part of the. So that's not good for anybody.
是的。去对抗贩奴者。但他还没来得及上任就去世了，人们被发现在他的巴黎公寓里身亡。这不是一段很奇怪的人生吗？这简直可以写进惊悚小说的情节里。是的。不管怎样，这都是其中的一部分。所以这对任何人来说都不是好事。
Well, it's not good for the people of Whitehaven. I think it's fair to say, Adam. But the British still have a – the amazing thing is they don't give in. They don't just say, right, let's just cut our losses. Why not? Why do we keep going? Just pride? Stubbornness?
好吧，这对怀特黑文的人民来说可不是什么好事，亚当。但英国人依然拥有——令人惊叹的是，他们就是不肯认输。他们不只是说，好吧，及时止损吧。为什么不呢？为什么他们还要继续打下去？仅仅是因为骄傲？固执？
I think yes. I think those things. I mean, that really is a great question because by this point, the support in the House of Commons for Lord North is ebbing away. It starts losing some critical votes. I mean, there are plenty of people in Britain by this point saying, let's cut our losses and get out. But it's a massive thing. It's a massive thing to acknowledge the independence of these 13 colonies, you know. But also, I i mean as late as
我想是的。我认为有这些因素。我的意思是，这确实是一个极好的问题，因为到了这个时候，下议院对诺斯勋爵（Lord North）的支持正在逐渐消退。他开始在一些关键投票中失利。我的意思是，当时英国有很多人都在说，让我们及时止损，抽身离开吧。但承认这13个殖民地的独立是一件极其重大事情。不过，即使在……
1780 britain is still winning victories they are so they win a the battle of camden which for any londoner is a kind of an amusing idea um that's south carolina isn't it yes yes south carolina not in north london and they're fighting in the south because there is and actually this is a good answer to your your question dominic i mean as tom as tom is implying there, there is still this thought, well, maybe we can turn this around. And they're fighting in the South, not least because in the South they have good reason to believe there are still lots of loyalists there. And there are, there are loyalist groups who are irregular forces who are fighting to try to support the british and so the famous story of an american independence fighter who gets turned of course is benedict arnold um and uh he is um so what was he he was a kind of very distinguished general kind of very energetic general uh kind of loses his mobility he he gets
1780年，英国依然在赢得胜利。他们赢得了一场战役——卡姆登战役，对任何一个伦敦人来说，这都是个挺有趣的念头——那是南卡罗来纳州，对吧？是的，是的，南卡罗来纳，不是伦敦北部。他们在南方作战，因为——实际上，这正好能回答你刚才的问题，多米尼克。正如汤姆刚才暗示的那样，当时依然存在这样一种想法：也许我们还能扭转乾坤。他们在南方作战，很大程度上是因为他们在南方有充分的理由相信那里仍然有大量的效忠派。确实如此，有一些由非正规军组成的效忠派武装正在战斗，试图支持英国人。其中最著名的故事就是一个美国独立战士被策反了，当然就是本尼迪克特·阿诺德（Benedict Arnold）。
badly injured in his legs but it's still very kind of feisty yes um and feels that he's not getting the credit that he's owed yes he's not being promoted because he's from the wrong place and there's all this business about the continental congress wanting to share out the commissions among the different states and all this kind of thing and he's clearly a kind of prickly ambitious figure who doesn't think he's getting his fair dues he's also married to a beautiful woman Peggy Shippen who is a loyalist from a loyalist family anyway in Philadelphia and he as you say he gets turned and he thinks actually maybe I could get more accolades and get more glory if I defect to the British side. And it goes wrong from his point of view.
他曾经是一位非常杰出的将军，非常有活力，后来腿部受了重伤，失去了原有的机动性，但依然非常顽强。他觉得自己没有得到应得的荣誉，没有获得晋升，因为他来自错误的地方。当时大陆会议有一堆要在不同州之间分配军衔的破事。他显然是一个极其敏感且野心勃勃的人物，认为自己没有受到公平对待。此外，他娶了一位美丽的妻子佩吉·希彭（Peggy Shippen），她来自费城的一个效忠派家庭。总之，正如你所说，他被策反了，他认为或许如果自己投靠英国一方，能获得更多的赞誉和荣耀。但从他的角度来看，事情最后搞砸了。
I mean, he ends up, he survives. Because he gets offered the command of West Point, doesn't he? And it's suggested that he has this over. He's going to surrender. The plan is he's going to surrender West Point to the British, but the plan is exposed before he can do that. He manages to escape. His wife, Peggy, eventually manages to escape as well. And they're reunited in London. But the guy who'd
我的意思是，他最后活了下来。因为他被许诺担任西点军校的指挥官，对吧？有人建议他把西点军校交出来。计划是他要把西点军校向英国人投降，但这个计划在他付诸行动之前就败露了。他设法逃跑了。他的妻子佩吉最终也设法逃脱了。他们在伦敦重聚了。但那个负责传递情报的信使——约翰·安德烈少校（Major John Andre）被美国人俘虏了。他是英国人。他确实是英国人。他被当作间谍处决了。他被绞死了。不是像一个绅士那样被枪决，而是被绞死了。甚至连那些俘虏他、在处决前的几个星期里看守他的美国人，都对这个人倾倒不已。他们认为约翰·安德烈是极其伟大的军事人物，风度惊人、勇敢无畏。当他走向最后的刑场时，他依然感到震惊，因为他以为自己会被枪决，直到他看到绞架悬挂在那里。当被问及是否有遗言时，他说：“请为我作证，我像一个勇敢的人一样承担了我的命运。”所有人都惊叹：“哦，多伟大的风度啊！”他们太让人惊叹了。所以，美国人仍然完全有能力欣赏英军中的军官。
been running the messages, Major John Andre, is captured by the Americans. And he's British. And he is British. And he is executed as a spy. And he's hung. He's not shot, as a gentleman should be, but he's hung. And even the Americans who capture him and are holding him prisoner in the weeks before he's executed think they just swoon over this guy. They think John Andre is the most magnificent military figure, astonishing, bearing brave and when he walks out and to his final execution and he's still astonished because he thinks he's going to be shot until he sees the news hanging there and he's asked if he wants to say any last words and he says bear me witness that i bear my fate like a brave man and they all go oh how, how magnificent. And they're so scary. So there's absolutely a sense still that the Americans are capable of admiring officers in the British Army.
（注：原广播中主播口误或重复，此处合并译文）
But equally, there is also a figure who is up there in the annals of infamy alongside Benedict Arnold, who is a British officer called Benastre Tarleton. Brilliant name. And he is the guy who inspires what's his name in the patriot the kind of the villainous mel gibson's villain but he's a tremendous man isn't he benastre tarleton he looks gallant he kind of looks the part and uh he he kind of wins a battle and and the um the his opponents surrender and then he all his men slash them and kill them um and so this is uh tarleton's quarter it's called the tarleton complained that he'd been actually his horse had been shot from under him and he'd been
同样，在臭名昭著的史册中，还有一个与本尼迪克特·阿诺德齐名的英国军官，名叫班纳斯特·塔尔顿（Banastre Tarleton）。一个很棒的名字。他就是电影《爱国者》里那个反派的原型——梅尔·吉布森电影里的那个反派。但他是个了不起的人，对吧，班纳斯特·塔尔顿？他看起来英勇潇洒，很有军人的派头。他赢了一场战役，然后他的对手投降了，接着他所有的手下冲上去把对方砍倒并杀死——
stuck under the horse so he wasn't in position to but i mean you could argue couldn't you tom to go back to the thing we were talking about in previous episodes that if the british army had been had rather more tarletons and fewer gentlemen johnnies or whatever they were called then maybe they would have done a bit better than sort of playing by the Queensbury rules, which they're sort of doing throughout. Is that fair, Adam? Or am I being too ruthless? It certainly would have created a different outcome. But as we were saying before, all the time the British are saying, well,
这就是所谓的“塔尔顿的四分之一”（Tarleton's quarter，意指不留俘虏）。塔尔顿辩称，实际上当时他的马被击中倒地，他被压在马底下，所以他当时根本不在场……不过你也可以辩称，汤姆，回到我们之前几集讨论过的话题：如果英国军队里能有更多像塔尔顿这样的人，而少一些什么“绅士约翰尼”（Gentleman Johnny）之类的人，那他们是不是能比一直以来那种严格按照“女王斯伯里规则”（Queensbury rules，指骑士精神或正规作战规则）打仗做得更好一些呢？这样说公平吗，亚当？还是说我太冷酷无情了？这当然会创造出一个不同的结果。但正如我们之前所说，英国人一直在说：
it's a hearts and minds strategy. And they just don't quite bring themselves to do it. And really, if every British general had been a bloody Ben Tarleton, I mean, is it going to fundamentally change the story? I don't think it is. All it would have done is to really even further entrench. Poison
“这是一个争取民心的战略。”他们只是狠不下心来真正那样做。说实话，如果每个英国将军都像血腥的本·塔尔顿那样，这会从根本上改变故事的走向吗？我不认为会。这么做只会让敌对情绪更加根深蒂固。
relations, wouldn't it? Yeah. Just to go back to the question I asked 10 minutes ago, which was about why Britain kept fighting, why Britain didn't throw. I suppose one answer is that the british i mean nobody knows how the story will end so nobody knows that all 13 colonies will become independent as you said there are still lots of loyalists in let's say south carolina or north carolina or wherever so perhaps do the british think you know what the south is quite lucrative for its plantations. We could keep those states. Okay, New England is gone,
毒化关系，对吧？是的。回到我十分钟前问的那个问题：为什么英国人要继续打下去？为什么英国人没有放弃？我想其中一个答案是，英国人——没有人知道故事的结局会怎样，所以没有人知道这13个殖民地最终都会独立。正如你所说，在南卡罗来纳或北卡罗来纳或无论哪个地方，依然有大量的效忠派。所以，英国人会不会觉得，南方的种植园经济相当lucrative（赚钱），我们可以保住这些州？好吧，新英格兰是没了，
maybe Pennsylvania, wherever, but Virginia, the Carolinas. Well, because of course, with the French entering the war, there's the risk that the Caribbean colonies might go as well. And the British are facing the prospect of losing all their colonies in the new world. So the fact that they're able to hold onto to their Caribbean colonies suggests that that's not entirely a foolish strategy, right? Well, I think, yes, they're always trying to hold on to the Caribbean colonies, number one. I mean, that is the thing that they absolutely cannot happen is that the French and Spanish would take Jamaica and Antigua and Barbados. Did people in London envisage some scenario whereby some of the southern colonies remained loyal?
也许宾夕法尼亚也没了，不管哪儿都行，但弗吉尼亚、卡罗来纳……嗯，因为随着法国参战，加勒比海的殖民地也有丢失的风险。英国人面临着失去他们在“新世界”所有殖民地的可能。所以他们能够保住加勒比海殖民地这一事实表明，这并非完全愚蠢的策略，对吧？嗯，我想是的，他们一直在极力保住加勒比海的殖民地，这是第一点。绝对不能发生的事情，就是法军和西军夺走牙买加、安提瓜和巴巴多斯。伦敦的人民是否曾设想过某种南部殖民地保持效忠的剧本？
Yes, they definitely did. All options were still on the table, I think. And that's no doubt part of the reason why the war continued. And as Tom said, they're still winning battles. So they take Savannah. They take Charleston. They win this battle at Camden. The guy who wins that is General Cornwallis, who's from a Whig family.
是的，他们绝对设想过。所有的选项当时都还在桌面上，我认为。这无疑也是战争持续的部分原因。正如汤姆所说，他们依然在赢得胜利。所以他们攻占了萨凡纳。他们攻占了查尔斯顿。他们赢得了卡姆登战役。赢得这场战役的是康沃利斯将军（General Cornwallis），他出身于一个辉格党家族。
You know, your classic, I mean, basically a casting agency who supplied an old Etonian to command a British army. But actually, he's really good at it. So Cornwallis is remembered as this terrible disaster. But he's won lots of battles. He fought in the Seven Years' War. He's famously gallant. He voted against the Stamp Act.
你知道的，你的标准——基本上就像是一个专门给英国陆军提供老伊顿公学毕业生的选角机构派来的人。但实际上，他真的很擅长带兵。所以康沃利斯在人们的记忆中被视为一场巨大的灾难，但他其实打赢了许多战役。他参加过七年战争，以勇敢闻名。他曾投票反对《印花税法》。
And he goes on to become Governor General in India, doesn't he? He does. He's not a kind of complete weed and a nothing, like he's remembered. And then once he's won Camden, he moves north, doesn't he? He moves into North Carolina. And he thinks, right, what I need to do is to cut the rebel supply lines from Virginia. So he ends up going into Virginia. And this is, I mean, it's so so that the camp we're not a military history
后来他去印度当了总督，对吧？是的。他可不是那种被人记住的废物软蛋。一旦他赢下了卡姆登，他就向北进军了，对吧？他进入了北卡罗来纳。他心想，好吧，我需要做的是切断叛军来自弗吉尼亚的补给线。于是他最终进入了弗吉尼亚。这——我的意思是，听着，我们不是一个军事历史
podcast is probably everybody can tell but he um he's sort of trudging this way and that's across the landscape and he ends up in a peninsula to use the technical language yeah that's exactly yeah some people may say that about this podcast that basically we trudge this way and that's but dominic you know historical but again you know what's intriguing about this podcast that basically we trudge this way and that's a historical but again you know what's intriguing about this is that he knows what is coming so he's been commanded by general clinton to go and do this and he's saying no i think this is a terrible idea um but he you know he obeys but even as he's doing whatever it is he was saying trudging around he's kind of writing letters and keeping correspondence to make sure that you know he he will be able to say that he thought this was
播客，可能每个人都听得出来，但他——他就是这样一路艰难跋涉，穿过这片地形，最终困在了一个半岛上——用专业术语来说的话。是的，完全是这样。有些人可能会这样评价这个播客：基本上我们就是这样漫无目的地东拉西扯。但是多米尼克，你知道历史学……不过话说回来，你知道这其中最耐人寻味的是什么吗？他是知道接下来会发生什么的。克林顿将军命令他去这么做，而他说：“不，我觉得这是个糟糕的主意。”但他还是服从了。尽管他在做着那些他认为是在“艰难跋涉”的事情，但他一直在写信保持联络，好确保将来自己能够证明：“看吧，我早就说过这是个馊主意。”所以这又是一种失败主义的心态。他写信给克林顿说：“我向您保证，我对在这个国家到处行军寻找冒险已经感到十分厌倦了。”因为这就是现实，而这基本上就是他在做的事。他最终被困在了这个被称为威廉斯堡颈部（Williamsburg Neck）的半岛上，并在那里决定找个地方驻扎，一个叫约克镇（Yorktown）的地方。这是一个不错的基地。我可以在这里通过海路获得补给。这显然——这在某种程度上有那么一点亚克兴战役（Battle of Actium）的感觉，汤姆。你知道亚克兴战役吧，马克·安东尼和克利奥帕特拉在那里陷入了绝境，被屋大维的舰队封锁了。
a bad idea so again it's this sense of defeatism he said he writes to clinton i assure you i'm quite tired of marching about the country in quest of adventures because that's it and that's basically what he's doing and he ends up in this peninsula called the williamsburg neck where he decides there's a place called ytown. This is a good base. I'll get supplies from the sea here. And this obviously is, I mean, it's got a tiny bit of the feel of the Battle of Actium to it, I think, Tom. You know the Battle of Actium where they got kind of cornered, didn't they, Mark Antony and Cleopatra, blockaded by Octavian's fleet.
（注：原广播中主播口误或重复，此处合并译文）
And he basically manages to corner himself in this peninsula where Washington pitches up with the french they outnumbered him two to one and he's thinking well maybe i'll get supplied from the sea and then the french fleet sails into view and he thinks oh god it's all over that ship has sailed as it were yeah and and then um it's a swamp which is a very poor choice i think of uh topographical choice because they all get malaria. Half of his men get malaria. He realizes he's not going to be able to get out.
他基本上设法把自己逼进了这个半岛，而华盛顿带着法军突然出现，敌人的兵力是他们的两倍。他心想，好吧，也许我能从海上得到补给，接着法国舰队驶入了视野，他心想：“天哪，一切都完了，大势已去了。”然后——那是个沼泽地，我认为这是一个非常糟糕的地形选择，因为他们全都感染了疟疾。他手下一半的人都得了疟疾。他意识到自己根本无法突围。
They're all hungry, very miserable. And eventually, the 19th of October, 1781, Cornwallis says, enough. I surrender. And he's too ill to attend the ceremony himself. So he says. So he says. What is it with you cyn ceremony himself he says so he says what is it with you what is it with you cynics so he sends out his second in command doesn't he to surrender and so george washington refuses to accept the surrender from the second in command and asks his second in command to accept the surrender instead. The British would have been happy to surrender to the French,
每个人又饿又惨。最终，在1781年10月19日，康沃利斯说：够了，我投降。他病得太重，无法亲自出席投降仪式。所以他说——所以他说，你们这些讽刺鬼到底是怎麼回事？所以他派出了他的副手去投降。乔治·华盛顿拒绝接受来自副手的投降，并要求他自己的副手来接受投降。英国人本来很乐意向法国人投降，
but not to the American rebels. Because it's humiliating for them. And so they all walk out, don't they? They kind of have to walk for a kind of mile, a mile-long gauntlet. They have to run it. And then they have to hand over all their weapons. And so the British troops hurl down their muskets
但绝不愿意向美国叛军投降。因为那对他们来说太耻辱了。于是他们全都走了出来，对吧？他们不得不走过一条长达一英里的通道，像走一条严厉的防线一样。他们必须走过去，然后交出所有的武器。英国士兵们愤怒地把滑膛枪重重地扔在地上，
in the hope that they'll smash it up but it's been a very unsporting end they're not even allowed to play the right music and stuff and they're not allowed to carry their flags unfurled they have to furl their flags um but having said that washington then once the surrender has been completed invites um all the senior officers for a party which is wonderful except for except for one officer, who is, of course, Benastry Tarleton. So he remains the baddie that they love to hate. So Washington, unsporting behavior followed by very sporting behavior. But then six days after the surrender, he issues an order that says that all the slaves that have joined the British,
希望能把它们砸碎，但这实在是一场非常缺乏体育精神的结局。他们甚至不被允许演奏正确的音乐，也不被允许展开他们的军旗，他们必须把军旗卷起来。话虽如此，一旦投降仪式完成，华盛顿便邀请了所有的英国高级军官去参加一个派对——这本是个美妙的举动，除了一个人例外，这个人当然就是班纳斯特·塔尔顿。所以他依然是美国人又爱又恨的那个大反派。因此，华盛顿展示了缺乏体育精神的行为，紧接着又展现了极有体育精神的行为。但就在投降六天后，他下达了一道命令，要求所有加入英国军队的奴隶
my troops are now to round them up and return them to their owners, which is the kind of detail, Adam, that 21st century historians seize on as a sort of unsettling one in what's normally a very patriotic narrative. It is unsettling if you have swallowed the patriotic narrative that I suppose many Americans did over many generations. It's not in the slightest bit surprising, though, is it? I mean, they're in a slave society. The core thing about slavery is that it's a claim to property. And there would have been no possible alternative course of action for Washington himself, who, of course, is a slaveholder. And in a slaveholding state, colony of Virginiaia what else would he would you expect him to have done in that situation so there's no sense there that's bad
都被他的部队搜捕并归还原主。这就是亚当所说的那些细节，21世纪的历史学家们往往会抓住不放，认为这是在通常充满爱国主义叙事中一个令人不安的瑕疵。如果你全盘接受了许多美国人在世世代代中笃信的那套爱国主义叙事，这确实是令人不安的。不过，这其实一点也不让人意外，不是吗？毕竟，他们身处一个奴隶制社会。奴隶制的核心在于它是一种对财产的声索。对于华盛顿本人——他当然也是一个奴隶主——以及在弗吉尼亚这个蓄奴殖民地/州的背景下，除了这样做，根本不可能有任何其他的替代方案。所以你不会觉得这算是什么恶劣的行为吧？
behavior i mean almost everybody involved with the american cause would say that's that's exactly what we'd expect them to do no i wouldn't go that far because the the 13 colonies were diverse and complicated places. And I think, I mean, also, right, that in Northern states, in Philadelphia, particularly and in New England, that the process of the war gives a massive boost to abolitionism, as it has done in Britain as well, actually. It does. Yes. Yeah.
几乎所有参与美国独立大业的人都会说：“这正是我们所期望他们做的。”不，我不会走得那么远，因为那13个殖民地是多元且复杂的地方。我认为——同时你也得看到，在北方各州，尤其是费城和新英格兰，战争的过程对废奴主义起到了巨大的推动作用，正如它在英国所起到的作用一样。确实如此。是的。
So the impact of the American Revolution on slavery is a highly complex one. In some ways, it reinforces it. In other ways, it gives a huge boost to the anti-slavery movement. Both things are true simultaneously. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Let's take a break now. So, Cornwallis has surrendered. Effectively, it's the end of the war. But when we come back, let's look at how the war is officially concluded and then think about the short- and the long term consequences of it. and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
因此，美国独立战争对奴隶制的影响是一个高度复杂的问题。在某些方面，它巩固了奴隶制；但在另一些方面，它极大地推动了反奴隶制运动。这两点是同时存在的。是的，好吧。我们现在休息一下。所以，康沃利斯投降了。从实质上讲，战争已经结束了。但当我们回来时，让我们来看看这场战争是如何正式结束的，然后思考它的短期和长期后果。我们来告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. It's the final section of our four-part epic, the heroic Adam Smithith like george washington he's been in the field for what seems years his sword is still unsheathed and adam uh we're approaching the end and basically cornwallis's surrender that's it and is it recognized as such by everyone when the news gets back to London and Lord George Germain, who I actually don't think we've mentioned so far in this discussion, but he's the poor guy in London who's having to try to run the war on behalf of Lord North. He realises the significance of this. The King realises the significance of this. This isn't the only British army in the
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。这是我们四集史诗的最后一部分，由伟大的亚当·史密斯作客。就像乔治·华盛顿一样，他在战场上征战了似乎有数年之久，他的宝剑依然未曾入鞘。亚当，我们正在接近尾声，基本上康沃利斯的投降就意味着一切结束了。当这个消息传回伦敦，由乔治·日耳曼勋爵（Lord George Germain）——我想我们在这次讨论中之前还没提到过他，但他就是伦敦那个可怜的家伙，不得不代表诺斯勋爵设法统筹这场战争——当他得知这一消息时，所有人都意识到它的重大意义了吗？国王意识到它的重大意义了吗？这并不是英国在战场上的唯一军队。
field. The British still hold New York. They still hold Charlestown, Charleston, South Carolina. They've still got a military presence, but this is a blow from which they know they can't come back. And they're also, round about the same time, the French have won a victory at St. Kitts and the Spanish have just captured Menorca. So it's like playing one of those kind of strategy games where everything is going wrong at once.
英国人仍然控制着纽约。他们仍然控制着查尔斯顿，也就是南卡罗来纳州的查尔斯顿。他们依然保留着军事存在，但这绝对是一个让他们无法翻身的沉重打击。而且就在差不多同一时期，法军在圣基茨（St. Kitts）赢得了胜利，西班牙人刚刚攻占了梅诺卡岛。这就像是在玩那种所有事情同时出错的战略游戏。
You think, okay, it's time to cut the losses. But oddly, so this is a weird detail. Cornwall just surrenders in October 1781, but the Treaty of Paris is not for another two years. What's going on in the intervening two years? Well, partly what's going on is naval warfare in the Caribbean. So really the war, I mean, there are three different wars
你心想，好吧，是时候及时止损了。但奇怪的是——这是一个诡异的细节，康沃利斯在1781年10月投降，但《巴黎条约》直到两年后才签定。在这中间的两年里到底发生了什么？嗯，部分原因在于加勒比海的海上战争。所以实际上这场战争——我的意思是，当时存在着三场不同的战争……
happening simultaneously here. There's the war between the British regulars and the American troops, the Continental Army, which we've mostly been talking about. Secondly, there's a kind of civil war within the colonies, which we've referred to a little bit, but it's really important in some places, sort of loyalists and patriots and kind of really nasty, violent stuff. And then thirdly, there's the global conflict. There's Britain on the one hand and France and Spain on the other. And that war continues beyond Yorktown. And the naval battles that take place in the coming months,
这里同时在发生着好几件事。一方面是英国正规军与美军即大陆军之间的战争，这也是我们一直在谈论的主题。其次，殖民地内部还存在着某种内战，我们之前也略有提及，但在某些地方这真的非常关键，比如保皇派与爱国者之间的冲突，那种极其恶劣、充满暴力的内斗。然后第三点，是全球性的冲突。一方面是英国，另一方面则是法国和西班牙。这场战争在约克敦战役之后仍在继续。而接下来的几个月里爆发的海战，
which are British victories and which secure Antigua and the other sugar islands, that's the way in which the British in London would like to think that the war has ended. That's the note they want to end on. And that's important to their negotiators. And also, Adam, isn't it? Admiral Howe, who'd been in command of the naval fleet, the naval forces in the Revolutionary War, he's come back and he comes to the liberation of Gibraltar. So there's a sense in which Gibraltar is more important than America. Yes. So actually, from the British point of view, they come out of this thinking,
这些海战以英国的胜利告终，并确保了安提瓜和其他产糖岛屿的安全，伦敦的英国人正是希望以这种方式来为战争画上句号。这才是他们想要结束战争的基调。这对于他们的谈判代表来说至关重要。而且，亚当，不是吗？曾指挥革命战争中海军舰队的海军上将豪勋爵也回来了，他参与了解放直布罗陀的行动。所以从某种意义上说，直布罗陀比美洲更重要。是的。因此，实际上从英国人的角度来看，他们经历这一切之后的想法是，
okay, well, we lost the colonies. That's been a bit of a disaster. But actually, in the grand scheme of things, we've got out of this. We've dodged the bullet. It could have been much worse. Right. It could have been much worse. And in a way, the fact that everybody's ganged up on Britain,
好吧，我们失去了殖民地。这算是一场灾难。但实际上，从宏观大局来看，我们总算脱身了。我们躲过了一劫。事情本可能变得更糟。没错。事情本可能变得更糟。从某种意义上说，所有人都在联合起来对抗英国，
is that effectively revenge, as it were, for the Seven Years' War? And is that recognition that the Seven Years' War had put Britain up there to be shot at in a kind of preeminent position? I think that's absolutely right, Dominic. Yeah, that's exact. And it's a scary moment. People in London, that's what they're really frightened of, is this isolation in Europe. All of British foreign policy through the 18th century is to avoid, and into the 19th century is to avoid isolation in Europe of the kind that happens in the late 1770s and early 1780s. And they don't want that to happen again.
这实际上是不是七年战争的报仇雪恨呢？这是否也承认了七年战争曾把英国推向那个备受瞩目的至高无上的地位，从而也成了众矢之的？多米尼克，我认为这绝对是正确的。是的，完全如此。这是一个令人胆战心惊的时刻。伦敦的人民真正害怕的，就是在欧洲陷入这种孤立无援的境地。18世纪乃至19世纪贯穿英国所有外交政策的核心，就是避免在欧洲陷入类似于18世纪70年代末和80年代末那种孤立状态。他们绝不希望重蹈覆辙。
That's the lesson the British policymakers draw. Right. But actually, so Britain, I think it's fair to say, I mean mean obviously i i know our remaining american listener will say i've never heard such a i've never heard such a partisan podcast in my life triopic tosh but it's fair to say that the british have made a series of very bad mistakes from the start of this series to right to this point yeah but in a weird way the british really distinguish themselves with the peace, don't they? Because they get the Americans to sign a peace.
这就是英国决策者们汲取的教训。没错。但实际上，英国人——我觉得这样说很公平，当然我知道我们剩下的美国听众会说“我这辈子从来没听过这么偏颇的播客，简直是废话连篇”——不过平心而论，从这个系列节目的一开始到现在的关键节点，英国人确实犯了一系列非常严重的错误，对吧？但在某种奇怪的层面上，英国人在缔结和平条约时确实表现得非常出色，不是吗？因为他们成功让美国人签署了和平协议。
They do a deal with the British alone and they give the Americans much more generous terms than the French or the Spanish want them to. Absolutely. And Franklin's negotiating it in Paris, isn't he?
他们单独与英国人达成协议，并且给予美国人的条件，比法国或西班牙希望给予的要慷慨得多。确实如此。富兰克林当时正在巴黎进行谈判，对吧？
Yes. And he's a kind of very free-form negotiator. You know, the British say, let's do this. And he goes, yeah, why not? Brilliant. The story of the Treaty of Paris is usually told as a great triumph for Franklin's negotiating skills. And no doubt the Americans did do a good job. But fundamentally, what this is about is that the British definitely did not need to agree such generous terms to the new United States. But it was in Britain's interest to do that.
是的。他是一个非常不拘一格的谈判代表。你知道，英国人说，我们这样做吧，而他则说，行啊，为什么不呢？太棒了。人们在讲述《巴黎条约》的故事时，通常将其描述为富兰克林谈判技巧的伟大胜利。毫无疑问，美国人确实做得很好。但从根本上讲，这是因为英国人完全没有必要向崭新的美国开出如此慷慨的条件。不过，这样做符合英国的利益。
Once the 13 colonies had been lost, it was in Britain's interest to have a reasonably strong United States in North America as a bulwark against the French. Yeah, and also presumably to keep them on board because there's Canada and there's the Caribbean as well. Indeed. And the worst outcome in the Treaty of Paris for Britain would have been France reclaiming some of her possessions in North America or Spain doing likewise. And so a weak, fragmented, tiny United States just clinging to the atlantic seaboard which would have been certain to invite another war very soon that wouldn't have been in britain's interests either so long as they wanted to hold as you say tom as long as they wanted to hold on to their possessions in canada and just on i mean people will often talk about the um what the americans call the revolutionary war and we call the american war of. People often talk of it as a civil war. When it's over, I mean, when they are meeting Franklin,
一旦13个殖民地丢失，对英国而言，符合自身利益的做法是在北美扶植一个足够强大的美国，以此作为对抗法国的屏障。是的，而且大概也是为了稳住美国，因为那里还有加拿大，也有加勒比地区。确实如此。对于英国来说，《巴黎条约》中最糟糕的结果莫过于法国重新夺回她在北美的部分领土，或者西班牙也效仿此举。因此，一个虚弱、四分五裂、只死死抓着大西洋沿岸狭长地带的微型美国，注定很快就会招致另一场战争，这同样不符合英国的利益——只要他们还想保住——正如你所说，汤姆——只要他们还想守住他们在加拿大的领土。而且就在——我的意思是，人们经常谈论所谓的美国人称之为独立战争、而我们称之为美利坚战争的这场冲突。人们经常把它当作一场内战来看待。当这一切结束时，我的意思是，当他们与富兰克林会面时，
who used to play chess with British guys when he was in London before the war, is there bad blood? Or are they all sort of shaking hands and drinking port and kind of chuckling about funny things that happened at Saratoga or whatever. I mean, what's the sort of atmosphere like between Britain and America in the immediate aftermath? There's a very emotional moment when John Adams comes to London as the first minister from the new United States and he's presented at court and he has a conversation with the king. And they're both very emotional about this and the king certainly so. But John Adams pledges the future friendship of the United States
他在战前身在伦敦时曾和英国人一起下过国际象棋，他们之间现在还记仇吗？还是说大家都在握手言欢、喝着波特酒，顺便对萨拉托加或其他地方发生的趣事付之一笑？我的意思是，在冲突刚结束的直接余波中，英国和美国之间的气氛到底是怎样的？当约翰·亚当斯作为新美国的首任公使来到伦敦时，发生了一个非常感人的时刻：他被引见给国王，并与国王进行了交谈。对此他们二人都情绪激动，尤其是国王肯定如此。但约翰·亚当斯承诺了美国未来的友谊，
and emphasizes all the common ties of culture and language and religion and with the strong implication that now this late unpleasantness is behind us, at the end of the day, we are now like you and like we've always been, a great Protestant power. And we know who our enemies are. They're the French. And that was why Thomas Jefferson, in contrast, did not go down so well. So the answer to your question, Dominic, is it depends on which Americans you're talking about.
并强调了文化、语言和宗教方面的所有共同纽带，其强烈暗示是，既然这段晚近的不快已经过去，归根结底，我们现在就像你们一样，也像我们一直以来那样，是一个伟大的新教国家。而且我们清楚谁是我们的敌人。敌人就是法国。正因如此，相比之下，托马斯·杰斐逊就没有那么受欢迎了。所以，多米尼克，你问题的答案是，这取决于你指的是哪群美国人。
Because Jefferson is a shameless Francophile, isn't he? He is, and he remains a shameless Francophile, isn't he? He is, and he remains a shameless Francophile, even into the 1790s. As the guillotine is falling, Jefferson is toasting the chateau of the American Revolution falls on France rather than on Britain, because French support for the American war effort costs them a lot of money, bleeds them of so much money that it precipitate the revolution. And you talked about America being Protestant. But one of the other interesting kind of corollaries of the war period is that Jefferson is able to make the case for there being kind of wide-scale religious tolerance. And that is something that simply because the
因为杰斐逊是个毫不掩饰的亲法分子，对吧？他的确是，而且他甚至到了1790年代依然是个毫不掩饰的亲法分子。当断头台落下时，杰斐逊还在为法国干杯。美国革命的果实落在了法国身上，而不是英国身上，因为法国对美国战争努力的支持耗费了他们巨额资金，让他们元气大伤，从而直接催生了法国大革命。刚才你谈到美国是一个新教国家。但战争时期另一个有趣的衍生结果是，杰斐逊能够为大规模的宗教宽容争取到立足之地。而这之所以能够实现，纯粹是因为
structures of kind of establishment churches are no longer able to be maintained. And so that's another very, very significant fruit of the Revolutionary War, isn't it? Yes. I mean, pretty much everybody imagines that the religious toleration is within a Protestant context. It's a different matter being entirely tolerant of Catholics and nevermind non-Christians. But once it's been kind of written into the constitution, then a bit like the Declaration of Independence, these are slow burners that will burn their way through American history. Yeah, that's right. And disestablishment happens across the new United States in those places that still have a church establishment quite quickly afterwards.
国家建制教会的结构已经无法再维持下去了。所以这也是独立战争另一个非常非常重大的成果，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，几乎所有人都认为这种宗教宽容仅限于新教的语境之内。要完全容忍天主教徒，更不用说非基督徒了，那是完全不同的另一回事。但一旦这种理念被写入宪法，它就会像《独立宣言》一样，成为在美洲历史中徐徐燃烧并产生深远影响的火种。是的，没错。而且在新美国的各个地方，那些原本仍设有国教的地区，政教分离很快就在随后发生了。
Massachusetts is the last, I believe, is the last state to disestablish its church. So they hold the Puritan tradition clings on there for a long time. But that's also something that's deeply ingrained in their sense of being of English liberties. They wouldn't have regarded that as something that's entirely new. They would have said, well, we've always had religious liberty, or we thought we had, and the American Revolution has given it an impetus. And it's focused, you know, the Church of England and the church establishment was clearly associated and in place like virginia which had an established anglican church associated with tories and support for the king and so they were delegitimized yeah so there's that great
据我所知，马萨诸塞州是最后一个将教会与国家分离的州。因此，清教传统在那里顽强地坚守了很长一段时间。但这同样深深根植于他们对英国自由传统的感知之中。他们不会把这视为一件完全崭新的事物。他们会说，我们一直都拥有宗教自由，或者我们以为自己拥有，而美国革命只是赋予了它一股新的推动力。这也成为了焦点，你知道，英国国教会以及各地的建制教会显然都与托利党人以及对国王的支持紧密相连——比如在弗吉尼亚州，那里就曾有一个确立的英国国教会，与托利党人和王室支持者挂钩，因此它们失去了合法性。是的，所以这就引出了杰斐逊那句名言，
thing right from jefferson it does mean no injury for my neighbor to say there are 20 gods or no god it neither picks my pocket nor breaks my leg and i guess only someone who's been through a very violent war could maybe have made that made. Yeah. So Thomas Jefferson himself had not actually been through a violent war. He had a war in France. But yes, no, but I take your point. But Jefferson's sort of performative secularism was not typical. I mean, you know, most of the rest, I mean, Jefferson did say he was a deist and Tom Paine, of course, was certainly performatively non-religious, but not the rest of them. The rest of them were all very pious church attending
邻居说有二十个神或者没有神，既不损我的钱包，也不断我的腿。我想，只有经历过一场极其残酷战争的人，或许才能说出这样的话。是的。因此，托马斯·杰斐逊本人实际上并没有经历过血腥的战争。他在法国度过了战争时期。不过，是的，不，我明白你的意思。但杰斐逊那种表现性的世俗主义并不具有代表性。我的意思是，你知道，其余大多数人——我的意思是，杰斐逊确实说过他是个自然神论者，而托马斯·潘恩当然在表现上也绝对是非宗教的，但其他人并非如此。其余的人都非常虔诚，都是去教堂的
Presbyterians or Congregationalists. But Jefferson is a kind of sign of how far that can be pushed and that kind of brief window where it's possible to establish a new country on broadly enlightenment principles yeah tom you love jefferson but i can tell from that i don't love jefferson the way that adam uses the word performatively i mean he's the rankest of the of hypocrites oh he is he's a terrible one right he ranks tom with um bogey douglas john lennon and Virginia Woolf as absolute enemies, sworn foes of the rest of history and some of the worst people who've ever lived. Now, I don't include John Lennon in that. Before we move on to the future for the United States, there is, of course, one other country in North America that was created by these years, and that is Canada.
长老会教徒或公理会教徒。但杰斐逊某种程度上体现了这种理念能被推到多远，以及那个短暂的窗口期——在这个时期内，完全有可能基于广泛的启蒙运动原则来建立一个新的国家。是的，汤姆，你深爱着杰斐逊，但我从你的话里听出，我可不像亚当那样崇拜杰斐逊——我是说，他是最彻头彻尾的伪君子。哦，他确实是，他是个可怕的伪君子！没错，汤姆把他和鲍比·道格拉斯、约翰·列农以及弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫并列为绝对的敌人、历史其余部分的死敌，以及有史以来最糟糕的一些人。不过，我可不把约翰·列农算在其中。在我们转向探讨美国的未来之前，当然还有北美洲由这些岁月所孕育的另一个国家，那就是加拿大。
Is that too strong to say that this is the foundational moment of Canada? No. I mean, Canada as an entity doesn't exist quite at this point, but by definition, it exists because it's British North America. And that's what people begin to refer to. It's British North America. And everything that happens in British North America is also happening in the United States. And it's a place of relative religious freedom and relatively high levels of political participation and access to land and
说这是加拿大的奠基时刻，会言过其实吗？不会。我的意思是，作为一个实体的加拿大在此时此刻尚未完全成型，但从定义上讲它已经存在了，因为它就是英属北美。这也是人们开始称呼它的名字：英属北美。而且在英属北美发生的一切，同时也正在美国发生。那是一个相对享有宗教自由、有着极高政治参与度和土地获取途径的地方，
wars with indigenous people and stories of exploitation. What it doesn't have is slavery, and it doesn't have a Republican constitution, but it develops and flourishes and prospers. And Canadian history begins at this moment. So that's Canada. The United States. So suddenly the United States, 1783, its independence has been recognized by Britain, which must seem like an absolutely extraordinary moment. Of course, they've thought of themselves as independent since the mid-1770s,
同时也伴随着与原住民的战争以及种种剥削的故事。它所没有的是奴隶制，也没有共和宪政，但它不断发展、繁荣并兴旺起来。加拿大的历史正是从这一刻开始的。这就是加拿大。再来看看美国。突然之间，在1783年，美国的独立得到了英国的承认，这在当时一定显得是一个极其非凡的时刻。当然，他们自17世纪70年代中期以来就一直认为自己是独立的，
but now they have it de jure as well as de facto. But is the United States a nation at that point? Surely it's just 13 different colonies in an uneasy confederation. In an uneasy confederation, in a dangerous world with no template that they can follow. Well, ancient Rome, perhaps? Well, they're looking to ancient Rome. Some are even looking at Swiss republics, the Dutch Republic. And there are historical precedents. The ancient ones are the most relevant.
但现在他们不仅在事实上（de facto），而且在法律上（de jure）真正拥有了独立。然而，当时的美国真的算是一个国家吗？它肯定只是一片由13个不同的殖民地组成的、处于不安定状态的邦联吧。处于一个不安定状态的邦联中，身处一个危险的世界，而且没有任何可以效仿的模板。嗯，或许可以效仿古代罗马？好吧，他们的确在借鉴古代罗马。有些人甚至在研究瑞士共和国、荷兰共和国。历史上确实有先例可循。而古代的先例才是最相关的。
Because the assumption is at this point in European society that republics basically implode. Yeah. That's the assumption, that they're inherently unstable. Yeah. But I mean, they are unstable at first, aren't they? They've got Shays' Rebellion. They've got lots of local issues unresolved. They've got the issue of the Native Americans on the frontier. Who knows that the French might not come back? The British might come back. And they have no leadership, no capital, no government, really, do they, at this point? No. I mean, effectively, the Articles of Confederation are really more like a kind of peace treaty among these 13 newly independent
因为当时欧洲社会的普遍假设是，共和国基本上都会从内部崩溃。是的。这就是当时的假设，即它们本质上是不稳定的。是的。但我的意思是，它们最初确实很不稳定，不是吗？他们经历过谢斯起义。有许多地方问题尚未解决。边境地区还有美洲原住民的问题。谁知道法国人会不会卷土重来？英国人会不会卷土重来？而且他们在这个时候没有领导层，没有首都，也没有真正的政府，不是吗？没有。从本质上讲，《邦联条例》实际上更像是这13个新独立国家之间的一份和平条约，
states with no proper executive. They theoretically have treaty-making power, but they've got no tax-raising ability. So it's a very shaky beginning for the newly United States. And then what, I mean, anybody who's seen the musical hamilton will know that alexander hamilton who we've not mentioned at all and james madison who i think we mentioned in passing that they are two of the key figures in creating a kind of national government and moving towards a constitution and a much stronger executive a president a monarch effectively um an elected monarch what is it that provokes them to do that? And why does everybody else, having been anti-government
并没有一个真正的行政机构。他们在理论上拥有缔结条约的权力，却没有征税能力。因此，对于崭新的美联邦来说，这是一个非常动荡的开端。那么，看过音乐剧《汉密尔顿》的人都会知道，亚历山大·汉密尔顿——我们之前完全没有提到过他——以及詹姆斯·麦迪逊（我想我们顺便提到过他），他们是建立某种国家政府、推动宪法制定以及建立更强有力行政权（即总统制，本质上是一个选举君主制）的关键人物。究竟是什么促使他们采取这一行动？为什么其他人在此之前长期反政府、反英国强权以及诸如此类的事情，现在却突然说“好吧，现在我们需要——”这究竟是因为恐惧？还是因为什么？从根本上讲，这就是恐惧，但正如其他历史学家所使用的那个词，这实际上是一场“支持政府”的革命。
and anti-British power and all that stuff for so long, why do they suddenly say, okay, well, now we need to – is it fear? What is it? Fundamentally, it is fear, but there is effectively a revolution in favour of government, to use a phrase that other historians have used. Well, it's their government, right? I mean, that's the key difference. It's not governments being practised on the other side of the ocean. It's their government and they can choose it.
嗯，这是他们自己的政府，对吧？我的意思是，这才是关键区别。这不是在大洋彼岸强加给他们的政府。这是他们自己的政府，而且他们可以选择它。完全正确。而且，你知道，约翰·亚当斯在《独立宣言》发表前后曾说过，一个远在数千里之外的政府身上有一种令人反感的东西。而整个这场运动的核心就在于，是的，我们要夺回控制权，建立一个属于我们自己的政府。好吧，他们拥有了代议制，所以现在他们可以收税了。是的，完全正确。但其中仍然存在一些持续不断的争议。我的意思是，抛开所有关于宪法制定的锱铢必较不谈，联邦主义者（即汉密尔顿、麦迪逊等人）与反联邦主义者（即杰斐逊）之间存在着一种紧张关系：关于
That's exactly right. And, you know, John Adams said around about the time of the Declaration of Independence that there's something odious in a government a thousand leagues away. And this whole movement is about, yes, taking back control and creating a government of our own. Well, they have representation, and so now they can have taxation. Yes, exactly. But there's a continuing needs about it. I mean, without getting into the whole, all the sort of the dotting the last I's and crossing the t's of the constitution making there's a tension between federalists which is hamilton madison and co anti-federalists which is jefferson about whether
是否应该拥有一个强大的国家、是否应该建立中央政府，还是应该让各州各自为政。如果说这种争论——发生在《巴黎条约》签署之后以及1787年费城制宪会议期间的争论——贯穿了整个美国历史，或者说这样说是不是过于简单化了，是将当下的美国政治辩论投射回了18世纪？辩论的性质在不同世代之间自然会发生变化，但这种根本性的紧张关系从一开始就存在。人们对建立一个更强有力的中央政府这一计划有着极大的不安和抗拒。人们对
or not there should be a powerful state whether there should be a central government whether you should just let the states get on with it and would it be too strong to say that that runs all that argument which is happening in the aftermath of the Treaty of Paris and then the adoption of the Constitution in Philadelphia in 1787? That runs all the way through American history, or is that just being too simplistic and back-projecting current American political debates to the 18th century? The nature of the debate changes, obviously, over the generations, but that fundamental tension is there right from the beginning. And there's huge unease and opposition to the project of creating a stronger central government. There's this huge discomfort with
尤其是总统职位感到极度不适，将其视为一个拥有特权权力的强力行政机构，而这些特权甚至远远超过了乔治三世。这是一种行政模式，一种基于对斯图亚特王朝君主制概念理解的单一行政长官。当然，这里有一个非常巨大的前提，即这个人是通过选举产生的，而不是拥有任何神圣授命或世袭的概念。尽管如此，这种宪法模式就像是光荣革命之前的英国宪法版本，拥有一个强有力的行政长官和一个独立选举、独立挑选的立法机构。不过话又说回来，其中确实带有一点罗马色彩，因为你拥有华盛顿这样的人物，这位伟大的将军曾引领他的人民、他的同胞公民，随后他又解甲归田。我的意思是，这就是这种形象。乔治三世本人曾说过，如果华盛顿能做到这一点，那他就是历史上最伟大的人，大意如此。而华盛顿确实做到了。他回到了弗农山务农，或者至少是让他奴役的人们为他务农。因此从某种意义上说，当美国人想到“我们需要这种带有君主色彩的总统”时，他们可以带着一定程度的自信这样做，因为他们手头拥有最理想的候选人——一个散发着古代罗马美德的人物。是的。我想我们可能还没有充分强调华盛顿的作用。华盛顿在战争期间塑造了怎样的形象。多米尼克，你曾问这算是一个国家吗？我的意思是，谁知道它算不算，当然你可以争论究竟是什么构成了国家，历史学家们也花大量时间在做这件事。但如果有什么东西真正塑造了一个国家，
the presidency in particular as a strong executive with prerogative powers that far exceed what George III had. A kind of model of executive, a single executive based on a kind of Stuart conception of kingship. Admittedly, with the pretty massive caveat that the person is elected rather than has any notion of being divinely appointed and being hereditary. But nevertheless, a model of the constitution that is like a kind of pre-glorious revolution English version of the English constitution with a strong executive and a separately elected, separately selected legislature. But again, there is a slight hint of the Roman about it because you have the figure of Washington, this great general who has led his people, his fellow citizens, and then he returns to his plow. I mean, that's the image of it. George III himself had said, if Washington does that, then he is the greatest man in history, or words to
那就是战争的经历。正是乔治勋爵华盛顿的形象，化身为了美国事业的化身，带着他的荣誉、他的正直，以及他似乎永不言谎的特质。这是一个迷人的问题。因此，这就引发了一个有趣的问题：带着他的荣誉、他的正直，以及他似乎永不言谎的特质。所以这是一个引人入胜的问题。因此，这就关于华盛顿提出了一个有趣的问题。美国人有幸拥有华盛顿这样一位能为他们提供一个凝聚焦点、英雄人物以及让国家团结在其周围的标志性人物吗？还是说他们无论如何都会产生这样一个人，并将这些特质投射到他身上？亚当，你觉得呢？换句话说，华盛顿是某种国家想象力的产物吗？嗯，这里面确实有一定道理。当时显然有一种渴望某种替代性父亲形象的心理。
that effect. And he does. He goes back to Mount Vernon and farms, or at least he gets his enslaved people to farm for him. So in a sense, when the Americans are thinking, you know, we want this kind of monarchical president, they can do that with a degree of confidence that they have the ideal candidate to hand, a figure of antique Roman virtue. Yes. And I think we probably haven't emphasised Washington enough, actually. The figure that Washington became through the war. I mean, Dominic, you said, is this a nation? I mean, who knows whether it's, I mean, you can argue about what makes a nation, of course, historians spend a lot of time doing so. But if anything has made a nation,
他们摆脱了一个“乔治”，但幸运的是，他们手头还有另一个“乔治”，在某些方面准备好接替这位被废黜的国王。他们很幸运，华盛顿是这样一个绝佳的人物，能够承载他们的欲望和希望。但我认为，这种说法极大程度地低估了华盛顿作为政治领袖的道德高度。因为如果你想想英国革命、美国革命、法国革命，英国革命催生了克伦威尔，法国革命催生了拿破仑，这两人基本上都变成了独裁式的人物。华盛顿没有。而这随后
it's the experience of war. And it's the figure of George Washington as the embodiment of the American cause with his honor and his integrity and his apparent inability to ever tell a lie. So that's a fascinating question. So that raises an interesting question about with his honor and his integrity and his apparent inability to ever tell a lie. So that's a fascinating question. So that raises an interesting question about Washington. Are the Americans fortunate to have somebody like Washington who gives them a focal point, a hero, a figure around which the nation can coalesce? Or were they always going to produce somebody like that onto whom they could project those qualities? What do you think, Adam? In other words, is Washington a creation of the kind of national imagination? Well, there's certainly something in that. There was evidently a yearning for some kind of replacement father figure.
确立了美国总统职位的整体基调，进而奠定了美国的性格：它不仅是一个共和国，而且从长远来看，也是一个民主国家。对此我非常赞同，汤姆。我认为华盛顿是一个伟人。而且我认为，在所有这些事件以及美国的创建过程中，我们或许确实需要更多地认可他的角色。是的，我也不知道这句话里的“我们”究竟指谁。好吧，我想，亚当，你指的可能是你的学术同行们，也就是那些研究美国革命和美国历史起源的学者们。因为当然了，现在这——不仅是学者们的事，它更是一个高度争议的政治领域。比如，人们现在更多地批评华盛顿蓄奴，而不是赞扬他击败英国——这在20年甚至30年前可能是闻所未闻的想法，但在如今的美国却相当普遍。
They got rid of one George, but fortunately they had another George ready to, in some respects, step into the shoes of the deposed king. They were fortunate that Washington was such a good figure on which to project their desires and hopes. But I think that question massively underplays the moral stature of Washington as a political leader. Because if you think of the English Revolution, the American Revolution, the French Revolution, the English Revolution throws up Cromwell, the French Revolution throws up Napoleon, both of whom essentially become dictatorial figures. Washington doesn't. And that then
是的。我的意思是，在这个故事的每一个阶段，以及你们俩在播客中讲述的所有故事中，都存在着巨大的偶然性，对吧？而你们俩最擅长的，就是总带着一种对其他可能性存在的感知来讲故事。这正是历史的本质。当然，我们所说的偶然性并不单单指纯粹的运气，而是指在每一个时刻对其他选择的意识。而乔治·华盛顿的个性塑造了那些关键时刻，以有益于未来稳定、并在某些方面有益于新创建美国的开放与自由的方式，塑造了这种偶然性。但请允许我问一句，其推论是否在于：如果华盛顿的威望就像是美国起源神话的基石——我这里用“神话”并不是贬义，我是说神话是一种强大、能够提升格调并激励人心的东西——但如果这块基石开始——你知道的，你开始动摇它、拉扯它、质疑它，这究竟是在增进美国人对自身过去的理解，从而为建设更好的国家开辟新的机遇？还是说，通过破坏这种起源神话，你实际上是在损害现存美国共和国的凝聚力与社会结构？我的意思是，
establishes the whole kind of tenor of the American presidency and therefore the character of the United States, not just as a republic, but in the very long run, a democracy as well. Strongly agree with that, Tom. I think Washington was a great man. And I think he probably is a figure that we need to recognize more for his role in all of these events and in the creation of the United States. Yes, I don't know who we is in that sentence either. Well, I guess, Adam, that you might be talking about your academic peers, the scholars who study the American Revolution and the origins of American history. Because of course, this is now, you know, it's not just a matter for scholars, it's highly contested political territory. And the idea that Washington might be criticized more for owning slaves, say, than for defeating the British, which would have been kind of unheard of idea maybe even 20 years ago, 30 years ago, is now quite current in America.
这是一个极其宏大的问题，但它似乎也笼罩着当代美国关于美国革命的许多争论。在当今的美国，人们对这样一个国家起源的故事深感不安：这个故事是围绕着伟大的人物、伟大的白人男性构建的，而这些伟大的白人男性中，有许多人曾自诩或实际拥有过其他人类的生命。其中就包括华盛顿本人，以及撰写了《独立宣言》的杰斐逊。还有作为宪法主要起草者的詹姆斯·麦迪逊。以及高呼“不自由，毋宁死”的帕特里克·亨利。人们对此深感不安。你可以理解为什么会这样——我的意思是，你完全可以理解，对吧？从某种意义上说，令人惊奇的是，直到21世纪的今天，这种批判才在民间获得如今这样的影响力。我想你在之前的节目中也提到过，《纽约时报》的“1619项目”其根本价值就在于以一种非常直接的方式挑战了那种旧有的框架。它直接且刻意地用1619年——即失去自由的黑人踏上弗吉尼亚土地的那一年——取代了1776年，并宣称那才是美国真正的起源时刻，而不是1776年。当然，它们两者其实仍在同一个框架内运作，即必须存在一个起源时刻。无论是1776年还是1619年，在某种目的论的意义上，它们都在导向一个名为
Yes. I mean, at every stage in this story and in all the stories that you two tell on your podcast, there's huge contingency, right? And that's what you two do so well is to tell a story always with a kind of sense of alternative possibilities. And that's what history is. And by contingency, of course, we don't mean just sheer luck. We mean the kind of awareness of other options at every moment. And George Washington's personality shaped the key moments, shaped that contingency in ways that benefited the future stability and in some respects,
“美利坚合众国”的造物。所以最后一个问题留给你，亚当，因为对于那些听了这期节目的听众来说——应该说，他们花了两个星期才听完，但亚当你基本上是一口气录了大约四个小时。嗯，你们俩也是啊。我可不是后期配音的。我们只是随时向你抛出问题。这可不是梅根和哈里的播客。我们就坐在你旁边。
the openness and liberal freedom of the newly created United States. But can I ask then, the corollary of that is that if the stature of Washington is kind of like the foundation stone of the myth of America's beginnings, and I don't use myth in a pejorative sense. I mean, myth is something that is powerful and can be ennobling and inspiring. But if that foundation stone starts to kind of be, you know, you start to shift it, you tug at it, you kind of question it. Is that improving Americans' understandings of their past and therefore opening up new opportunities for kind of making a better state? Or is it by damaging the kind of the origin myth, are you damaging the coherence and the fabric of the American Republic as it exists now? I mean,
我们并不是分开录制问题的。所以亚当，美国革命的故事从这里开始将走向何方？因为当然了，它目前正处于激烈的争论中。人们在争论的正是你刚才所谈论的这些事情。但展望未来，你认为人们会走向何处？我的意思是，你认为当我们去波士顿走“自由之路”、去弗农山庄、或者在华盛顿特区漫步并参观所有这些遗址时所看到的爱国叙事，真的能存活下来吗？尽管它受到了《纽约时报》和学术界的挑战，但它是否已经深深根植于美国的想象力之中？还是说你认为在21世纪还会有更多的变革？
that's a massive question, but it is one that seems to shadow a lot of the debate in contemporary America about the American Revolution. There's a lot of deep discomfort in the contemporary United States with a story of the national origins, which is built around great men and great white men, and great white men, many of whom were the owners, claimed to be the owners of other human beings. Among whom was Washington himself and Jefferson, who wrote the Declaration of Independence. And James Madison, who was the principal author of the Constitution. And Patrick Henry, who said, give me liberty or give me death. There's deep discomfort about that. And you can understand why. I mean, you can understand why, can't you? And in a way, the remarkable thing is that it's taken until this point in the 21st
我不知道。但我认为，如果美利坚共和国要以某种类似于其现有形态的形式生存下去——当然，它是最古老的持续存在、且是一个极其古老的国家，美国拥有世界上最古老的成文宪法——如果它想要延续下去，它就需要它的起源神话。起源神话一直在演变，它从来不是一成不变的东西。应当有一种方式——而且也确实存在这样一种方式——去讲述美国革命、共和国的建立、《独立宣言》中那些振聋发聩的原则、共和主义的价值、对大众政治参与的承诺、开放性以及致力于成为人类避难所的承诺。应当以一种比过去两个世纪大部分时间里更具包容性的方式来讲述这个故事。而我之所以认为“1619项目”对我的某些老一代学术同行构成了如此巨大的挑战，
century for that kind of critique to have the popular purchase that it has now. And I think you mentioned in a previous episode, the New York Times 1619 project and the fundamental value of the 1619 project is to challenge that old framing in a very direct way. And so it's directly and deliberately replacing 1776 with 1619, the date at which unfree black people were landed in Virginia, and saying that that is the real origin moment of the United States rather than 1776. Of course, they're both still operating within the same frame, which is that there has to be a moment of origin. And in both cases, that 1776 or 1619 were in some teleological sense leading towards the creation of something called
正是因为他们担心，一旦将框架如此剧烈地改变，将焦点集中在种族和奴隶制问题上，其他一切都会随之崩塌。在美国学术界，确实有一些我的左翼同行、以及总体上更年轻一代的学者，他们正想这么做。他们想要抛弃整个民族国家的概念，将美国视为从根本上已经腐败的产物，并且无法想象在1776年或1787年建立的政治体框架内存在任何真正的解放。确实有这样的人。从我们英国人的角度来看，这种叙事有一个奇怪的衍生结果，即基本上认为美国独立战争中的殖民地居民是在为维护奴隶制而战。这荒谬地将大英帝国包装成了一个废奴主义的代理人——尽管大英帝国在适当的时候确实成为了废奴主义者，但绝不是在此时此刻，对吧？我的意思是，把英国殖民主义说成是这场冲突中的“好人”，并不能让他们洗脱罪责，因为这显然不是事实。尽管最初的《1619项目》文章暗示，捍卫奴隶制是美国革命的主要原因之一，并且美国奴隶主深切地焦虑于大英帝国正转向反奴隶制，但这种说法被大大夸大了。正如我们所讨论的，卡罗莱纳和弗吉尼亚的许多奴隶主确实对英国人会利用被奴役者来对抗他们感到极度恐惧，这是千真万ัป的。但要笼统地说美国革命是为了捍卫奴隶制而战，那就大错特错了。有些人直接将17世纪70年代13个美洲殖民地的分离与1861年南方各州的分离联系起来。在我看来，这种类比被过度渲染了，不仅因为在19世纪60年代，北方各州确实存在庞大的反奴隶运动，南方奴隶主有充分的理由认为他们的安全和奴隶财产将在联邦内部受到威胁，
the United States. So last question, Adam, for you, because you have been, I should say, for those listeners who've listened to this over two weeks, you've been listening to this over two weeks, but Adam has been doing this over basically the course of four hours in one go. Well, so have you two. I haven't been dubbed in. We've just been folding up the questions to you. It's not like Megan and Harry's podcast. We're there with you.
但在18世纪70年代，这种程度的威胁根本不存在。当时英国存在反奴隶运动，费城和新英格兰也存在反奴隶运动。但如果他们继续留在英国体制内，这种运动并不至于压倒并摧毁奴隶主的安全性。真正威胁到他们奴隶财产的，恰恰是参与叛乱本身。好了。亚当，我想我们已经够折腾你的了。这是一场精彩绝伦的表现。汤姆，我想“力挽狂澜的杰作”（tour de force）是形容这种表现的传统用语吧？是的，我会称之为一场“华盛顿式的战役”。
We don't do the questions separately. So Adam, where does the story of the American Revolution go from here? Because of course, it's so contested at the moment. People argue about precisely these things that you've been talking about. But as you look forward, how do you think people will go? I mean, do you think the patriotic narrative that we see now when we go to Boston, we do the Freedom Trail, or you go to Mount Vernon, or you walk around Washington, D.C., and you see all the sites. Do you think that will effectively survive? It's challenged in the New York Times and in the Academy, but effectively, it's too rooted now in the American imagination. Or do you think there will be more changes to come in the 21st century?
一场华盛顿式的战役。你当时就像是潜伏在福吉谷一样。没错。而且还没用上你自己的假牙。所以，如果你喜欢亚当的表现，并且此前还没听过他的节目，亚当在去年的这个时候也为我们录制了四个极其精彩的关于美国内战的节目，你可以在我们的各大频道上找到它们。亚当，你今天的表现太棒了。
I don't know. But I think that if the American Republic is going to survive in something like its present form, and of course, it is the oldest continuous, and it's an incredibly old country, the United States, the world's oldest codified constitution. If it's going to continue, then it needs its origin myth. The origin myth has always evolved. It's never a static thing. And there should be a way, and there is a way, of telling the story of the American Revolution and the founding of the Republic and those ringing principles of the Declaration of Independence and the value of republicanism and the commitment to popular participation in politics and openness and the commitment to being an asylum for mankind and all of these things, there should be a way of telling that story in a way that is more inclusive than has been the case over most of the last two centuries. And the reason why I think the 1619 Project has been so challenging to some of my academic colleagues of an older generation
我想你现在大概创造了本节目嘉宾出场次数最多的纪录了。真是莫大的荣幸。真是莫大的荣幸。好吧，我不知道你的所有学术同行是否都会把这视为一种荣幸，所以可别向他们大肆宣传。不过，多米尼克，我们必须提到亚当自己的播客。我们必须提到。那就是《最后的最佳希望》（The Last Best Hope）。
is because of their fear that by changing the frame so dramatically to focus on the question of race and slavery, then everything else will go. And there are certainly academic colleagues of mine in the United States on the left, and generally of a younger generation who want to do that, who want to throw out the whole concept of the nation state and who see the United States as fundamentally corrupted and can't imagine any true emancipation within the context of the polity that was created in 1776 or 1787. There are those people. And from the point of view of us in Britain, one of the weird corollaries of this narrative that basically the American colonists
《最后的最佳希望》。《最后的最佳希望》。在那里——如果听众去听《最后的最佳希望》，他们会听到本播客的另一位好朋友丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）解释吉尔迪人（Geordies，英国泰恩赛德地区的人）是如何塑造美国南方文化的。这简直让我惊掉下巴。
in the War of Independence were fighting to keep slavery is to cause the British Empire rather implausibly as an agent of abolitionism, which in due course, of course, it does become, but not at this point, right? I mean, it doesn't get British imperialism off the hook to say that actually they were the goodies in this, because that's clearly not true. There are insofar as the original 1619 articles suggested that defense of slavery was a principal reason for the American Revolution, and that there was
所以基本上美国的一切，全都是吉尔迪人干的。全都是吉尔迪人。谁能想到丹会得出这样的结论呢？所以亚当，非常感谢你。同时也感谢所有听众的收听，我们下期节目再见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
a deep anxiety on the part of American slaveholders that the British Empire was turning to anti-slavery, that is a great exaggeration. I mean, as we discussed, it was certainly true in the Carolinas and Virginia that plenty of slaveholders were terrified at the prospect of the British using enslaved people against them. It is not true, generally speaking, to say the American Revolution was fought in defense of slavery. There are people who directly make the connection between the secession of the 13 American colonies in the 1770s and the secession of the southern states in 1861. That is hugely overdrawn, in my opinion, not least because while in the 1860s, there was a big anti-slavery movement in the northern states, and there were genuine reasons for southern slaveholders to think that their security, their slave property would be undermined within the union.
请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将带你揭开娱乐产业的幕后面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
That just wasn't true to anything like the same degree in the 1770s. There was an anti-slavery movement in Britain. There was an anti-slavery movement in Philadelphia and in New England. It was not one that was going to overwhelm the slaveholders' security had they remained within the British Empire. What threatened their slave property was participating in rebellion. Okay. Adam, we've worked you hard enough, I think. That has been a tremendous performance. Tom, I think a tour de force is the time-honoured expression, isn't it? Yes, I would say a Washingtonian campaign.
在1770年代，情况完全不是这样。英国当时有反奴役运动，费城和新英格兰也有反奴役运动。如果他们留在的大英帝国之内，这场运动还不足以动摇奴役主的安全。真正威胁到他们奴役财产的是参与叛乱。好了，亚当，我想我们已经够累着你了。这是一场精彩绝伦的表现。汤姆，我觉得“力作”是流芳百世的赞誉，对吧？是的，我会说这是一场华盛顿式的战役。
A Washingtonian campaign. You were skulking in Valley Forge. That's right. And not with your own teeth. So if you've enjoyed Adam's performance and you haven't already heard him, Adam also did four terrific episodes for us about the American Civil War this time last year, which you can find on our various channels. Adam, you have performed.
一场华盛顿式的战役。你当时正躲在福吉谷。没错。而且还不是用你自己的牙齿。所以，如果你喜欢亚当的表现，而且还没听过他的节目，亚当在去年这个时候还为我们录制了四期关于美国内战的精彩节目，你可以在我们的各个频道上找到它们。亚当，你表现得太棒了。
I think you now hold the record, actually, for the most appearances on the rest of this show. What an honour. What an honour. Well, I don't know whether all your academic colleagues would consider it an honour. So don't advertise it to them. But also, Dominic, we must mention Adam's own podcast. We must. The Last Best Hope.
我想你现在实际上创下了本节目出场次数最多的记录。真是个荣誉。真是个荣誉。嗯，我不知道你所有的学术同事是否都会认为这是一种荣誉。所以别向他们宣传。不过，多米尼克，我们必须提一下亚当自己的播客。我们必须提。那就是《最后的最佳希望》。
The Last Best Hope. The Last Best Hope. On which, on which in a recent, if listeners go to The Last Best Hope, they will hear another friend of this podcast, Dan Jackson, explaining how Geordies shaped Southern American culture. You would stun me.
《最后的最佳希望》。《最后的最佳希望》。在节目中，如果听众去听《最后的最佳希望》，他们会听到本播客的另一位朋友丹·杰克逊，解释纽卡斯尔人是如何塑造美国南方文化的。你可真把我惊艳到了。
So basically everything in America, it's all about Geordies. It's all about Geordies. Who'd have thought that Dan would come up with that? So Adam, thank you very much. Thank you to everybody for listening and we will see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
所以基本上美国的一切，都跟纽卡斯尔人有关。都跟纽卡斯尔人有关。谁能想到丹会提出这种观点呢？所以亚当，非常感谢你。谢谢大家的收听，我们下期再见。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家单集以及优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。